the RSA cryptosystem is one of the
lovely and really important applications
of number theory in computer science so
let's stuff start talking about it
the RSA cryptosystem is what is known as
a public key cryptosystem which has the
following really amazing properties
namely anyone can send a secret
encrypted message to a designated
receiver this is without there being any
prior contact using only publicly
available information now if you think
about that it's really terrific because
it means that you can send a secret
message to Amazon that nobody but Amazon
can read even though the entire world
knows what you know and can see what you
sent to Amazon and Amazon knows that
it's the only one that can decrypt the
message you sent this in fact is hard to
believe if you think about it it sounds
paradoxical how can secrecy be possible
using only public info and in fact the
existence of this public key
cryptosystem has some genuinely
paradoxical consequences which kind of
are a mind bender so let me tell you
about one of them I don't know if you've
heard of mental chess but it's a
standard thing in the chess world chess
masters are so talented and have such
deep insight into the game that they
don't need a chess board and they don't
need chess pieces they can just go for a
walk through the on a country lane
talking to each other and saying pawn to
King four and and Knight to Bishop three
and just talking chess code and play an
entire chess game that way that's known
as mental chess it's quite impressive in
fact the grandmasters can play multiple
games of mental chess against opponents
who are staring at the chess board and a
win the great majority of the games of
course these are not against other
grandmasters but still okay so now this
is what I propose how about playing
mental poker if you know how to play
poker we deal out cards and we bet and
so on and my only condition is that I'll
deal
now that sounds like a joke and an
absurd thing for you to agree to do but
it's amazing
it's actually possible one of the famous
papers of rivest and Shamir was how to
play mental poker using public key
crypto so um I once tried to persuade a
feminine MIT beam who's it was a
physicist researcher about this and he
just wouldn't believe it he argued that
it was just impossible logically and
what he was thinking about was that if
you know how to compute a function then
of course you can figure out how to
invert it that is to say if I know how
to compute some function f of a number
and let's say that the function is one
arrow in that is an injection then if I
know what F of n is there's a unique end
that it came from so how can I not be
able to find N and it's an insight of
computer science and complexity theory
that says it's quite possible it's not
that you can't find the N that produced
F of n it's that the search for it will
be prohibitive there are in short
one-way func that is functions that are
easy to compute in one direction but
hard to invert they're easy to compute
but hard to invert in particular we're
thinking about multiplying and factoring
it is it's an observation that it's easy
to compute the product of two large
prime numbers we all know how to
multiply and in fact there are faster
ways to multiply them you know but the
current state of our knowledge of number
theory and complexity theory is that
given a number n that happens to be the
product of two primes it seems to be a
hopelessly hard in general to factor and
into the components P and Q now this is
an open problem it's similar to the P
equals NP question that famous open
problem it's actually a a weaker it's
quite possible that you could factor and
NP would not equal to NP but
nevertheless it's the same kind of
problem and more generally the existence
of one way function
is closely related to that P equals NP
question nevertheless even though it's
an open problem and theoretically has
not been settled either way it's widely
believed I mean the banks the
government's and and the commercial
world have really bet the family jewels
on the difficulty of factoring when they
use the RSA protocol so I like to make
the joke that my most important
contribution to MIT was being involved
in the hiring of our SNA so this is a
adi shamir our ron rivest and l US a--
an ailing Adelman back in the late 70s
when they first came up with these ideas
so let's look at the way this RSA
protocol actually works so here's what
happens to begin with you have to make
some information public so that people
can communicate with you so there's a
we're looking at two players here
there's a receiver who's going to get
encrypted messages and there's a sender
who is trying to send an encrypted
message to the receiver so what the
receiver does beforehand is generates
two primes P and Q now in practice you
want these to be pretty big primes
hundreds of digits and they will examine
in a moment the question of how you find
them but the receivers job is to find
two quite substantial large Prime's P
and Q chosen more or less randomly
because if you have any kind of
predictable procedure for how you got
them that would be a vulnerability but
if you just choose in the random then
there is enough Prime's in the hundreds
of digits that it's hopeless that people
would guess which one you wound up with
okay what you do to begin with this
multiply P and Q together which is easy
to do let's call that number N and now
the other thing that receiver is going
to do is find a number e that's
relatively prime to this peculiar number
P minus 1 Q minus 1 now as a hint you
might notice
that P minus 1 Q minus 1 is in fact oil
is function event fee of n but for now
we don't need to understand that this is
euler's function it's just the recipe of
what the receiver has to do find a
number eat it's relatively prime to P
minus 1 Q minus 1 again you don't want e
to be too small and we can we'll discuss
in a moment how do you find such an e
but the receivers job is to find such an
e on this pair of numbers e and n will
be the public key which the receiver
publishes widely where it can easily be
found by by anyone who cares to look for
it basically there's a phone directory
where if you want to know how to send
somebody a secret message you look them
up and you find the receivers name in
there and then you see his public key
and N and that's what you use to send
him a message now how do you use a it to
send him a message well I'll explain
that a minute but let's look at one more
thing that the the receiver needs to do
to set himself up the receiver is going
to find an inverse of this number e that
he's published in the part of his public
key modulo a P minus 1 Q minus 1 that is
this e since it's relatively prime to P
minus 1 Q minus 1 it will have an
inverse in Z star P minus 1 Q minus 1
let's let that inverse BD and of course
we know how to find it because you could
do that with the pulverizer D is the
private key that's this crucial piece of
information that the receiver has then
that the receive is not going to tell
anybody
only the receiver knows that because the
receiver chose the P and the Q and the e
more or less randomly maybe even as
randomly as they can manage and then
they find the D and that's their secret
okay that's what the receiver does how
does the sender send a message well to
send a message what the the the sender
wants to do is choose a message that is
in fact a number in the range from 1 to
N on
where we're thinking again of n if it's
a product of two primes of a couple of
hundred digits each then the product is
around 400 digits and so you can pick
any number any message M that can be
represented by a 400 digit number now
there's a lot of messages that will fit
within 400 digits and of course if it's
bigger you just break it up into 400
digit pieces so that that's the kind of
message you're going to send so the
message is going to be a number in this
range from 1 to N and what the sender is
going to do is look up the public key e
and the other part of the public key N
and raise the secret message to the
power e in Zn so we're going to compute
m to the e in Zn and send that encoded
message M hat so M hat is what we think
of as the encrypted version of the
message M so then we have the problem if
that's what the sender sends to the
receiver how does the receiver decode
the message M hat and the answer is the
receiver just computes M hat to the
power D the secret key also in the ring
Zn and the claim is that in fact that's
equal to M now you can check in a class
problem and it's easy to see that the
reason why that method of decrypting
works is precisely an application of
euler's theorem at least when m happens
to be relatively prime to n now the odds
of finding an M that's not relatively
prime to n are basically negligible
because it would because if you did find
such an M it would enable you to factor
only believe factoring is very hard but
in fact it actually works for all M
which is a nice theoretical result and
you'll work this out in a class problem
ok that's how it works the receiver
publishes E&N keeps a secret key D the
sender exponentiate s' the message to
the power e the receiver simply decodes
by raising the receive mess
edge to the power D and reads off what
the original was okay so we need to
think about the feasibility of all of
this because we believe that it's
impossible to to decrypt but there's a
lot of other stuff going on there the
players have to be able to perform and
let's examine what their
responsibilities and abilities have to
be so the receiver to begin with has to
be able to find large primes and how on
earth do they do that
well without going into too much detail
we can make the remark that there are
lots of primes
that is to say by appealing to the prime
number theorem we know that in among the
N digit numbers about log n of them are
gonna be primes so that you don't have
to go too long before you stumble upon a
random prime that is if you're dealing
with a 200 digit N and you're searching
for a prime of around that size you're
not going to have to search more than a
few hundred numbers before you're likely
to stumble on a prime and of course how
do you know that you stumbled on a prime
well you need to be able to check
whether a number is prime or not and
efficiently in order for this whole
thing to be feasible so we'll have to
discuss that briefly how do you test
whether or not a number is prime in an
efficient way the other thing the
receiver has to do is find an e that's
relatively prime to P minus 1 Q minus 1
but that's easy well it's easy because
first of all if you just kind of
randomly guess a medium-sized e and then
search consecutively from some random
number you've chosen in the somewhere in
the middle of the interval up to P minus
1 Q minus 1 again you're likely very
likely to find in a few steps a number a
that is relatively prime to P minus 1 Q
minus 1 how do you recognize that it's
row that it's relatively prime well you
just compute the GCD which we know how
to do using Euclid's algorithm so that's
really quite a fish
recognising that it's relatively prime
is easy and you and you just don't have
to search very many numbers till you
stumble on an e okay the other thing you
have to do is find the D that's an e
inverse modulo P minus 1 Q minus 1 and
again that is the extended you send a
Euclidean algorithm the extended GCD
namely the pulverizer so those are the
pieces that the receiver has to do now
let's look at this a little bit more and
think about the information about the
prime so the famous theorem about the
primes is their density which is if you
let a pie of n be the number of primes
less than or equal to n then it's a deep
theorem of number theory that PI of n
actually approaches a limit in an
asymptotic sense which we'll discuss in
more detail but that PI of n as n grows
gets to be very close to n over log n
that's the natural log of n and and then
now that's a deep theorem but in fact if
we want a self-contained treatment for
our purposes there's an exercise that
will be in the text on where we can
derive chebychev's bound which is weaker
than the tight prime number theorem but
chebychev's bound which can be proved by
more elementary means that's within the
ability of our own ability at this point
with the numbers here we have to be able
to show that n over 4 log n is a lower
bound on pi of n so basically that says
that if you're dealing with numbers
numbers of size n which means they're of
length log n a few hundred digits then
you only have to search maybe a thousand
digits before you're very likely to
stumble on a prime and if you search two
thousand digits it becomes extremely
likely that you'll stumble on a prime so
the primes are dense enough that we can
afford to look look for them providing
we can have a reasonably fast way to
recognize when a number is prime
well one simple way that it almost is
perfect but but works pragmatically
pretty well is called the phase the
Firma test but let me just emphasize
this remark I got ahead of
so fit if I'm dealing with 200 digit
numbers than about one in a thousand is
prime using just the weaker chebychev's
bound and that says that I don't have to
search too long only a few thousand
numbers to be able to find a prime and
you know a few thousand numbers is well
within the ability of a of a computer to
carry out providing that the test for
recognizing that a number is prime isn't
too time-consuming so one naive way that
that really almost works to be a
reliable prime ality test is to check
whether a firm oz theorem is obeyed from
us theorem the special case of euler's
theorem says that if n is prime then if
I compute a number a to the N minus 1
it's going to equal 1 in Zn and that's
gonna be the case for all a that are not
0 if n is prime now that means that if
this equality fails in Zn then I
immediately know a is not prime go on
search for another one okay so suppose
I'm unlucky or lucky and I choose an a
to test and it turns out that a to the n
minus 1 is 1 does that mean that n is
prime unfortunately not it might be that
there's that I just hit an N that
happened to satisfy firm us equation
even though and was not prime but uh it
it's not a very hard thing to prove that
if n is not prime then half of the
numbers are from 1 to N are not gonna
pass the Fermont test so if half of the
numbers are not going to pass the the
firm our test then what I can do is just
choose a random nonzero number in the
interval from 1 to N raise it to the N
minus first power and see what happens
and if n is not prime the probability
that this random number that I've chosen
fails this test is at least 1/2 so I try
it 50 times and if in fact 50 randomly
chosen a is in this in the interval from
1 to n all satisfy firmus theorem then a
there's a one chance in 2 to the minus
50th that in two to the 50th rather that
but and it's not prime that's a great
bet leap for it so that basically is the
idea of a probabilistic prime allottee
test now there's a small complication
which is that there are certain numbers
n where this property that half the
numbers will fail to satisfy for a mus
theorem are not true or doesn't hold
they're known as the Carmichael numbers
in they're known to be pretty sparse so
that really if you're choosing an end at
random which is kind of what we're doing
when we choose random Prime's P and Q
the likelihood that you'll stumble on a
Carmichael number is another thing you
just don't have to worry about
so really the firm op primality test is
a plausible pragmatic test that you
could use to pretty reliably detect
whether or not a number was prime what
was the last component of the powers
that we needed the receiver to have okay
so now we come to the question of why do
we believe that the RSA protocol is
secure and the first thing to notice is
that if you could factor n then it's
easy to break because if you can factor
n then you have the P and the Q and that
means you know what P minus 1 times Q
minus 1 is and therefore you can use the
pulverizer in exactly the same way the
receiver did to find the inverse of the
public key e you could find the easily
so surely if if you can factor then RSA
breaks no question about that what about
the converse well what you can approve
and there's an argument that's scheduled
in a class problem not fully in the book
is that if I could find the private key
D then in fact I could also factor in so
if I believe that factoring is hard then
in fact finding the secret key is also
hard and we could try to be confident
that our secret key is not going to be
found even given the public key now
unfortunately this is not the strongest
kind of security guarantee you'd like
because there's a logical possibility
that you might be able to decrypt
messages without knowing the secret key
maybe there's some other walk around
whereby you can decrypt the secret
message Emma had by a method other than
raising it to the dthe power and what
you really like is a theorem of security
that said that breaking RSA reading RSA
messages by any means whatsoever would
be as hard as factoring that's not known
for RSA it's an open problem and so RSA
doesn't have the theoretically most
desirable security assurance but we
really believe in it and the reason we
really believe in it is that for 100 or
more years mathematicians and number
theorists have been trying to find
efficient ways to factor and more
pragmatically on the most sophisticated
cryptographers and decoders in the world
using the most powerful networks of
supercomputers have been attacking RSA
for 35 years and have yet crackit now
the truth is that in the course of the
35 years various kinds of glitches were
found that required some added rules
about how you found the P and the Q and
how you found the e but they were easily
identified and fixed and an RSA really
is a robust encryption method public
encryption method that has a withstood
attack for all these years that's why we
believe it